this is uh the first uh
public presentation for um those who
don't know
of him uh of of the process
next after that will be his proposal
defense his
actual dissertation defense um
so he's uh going to present today
let me ask him is his committee here
um it looks like we might still be
waiting on
shannon no i i see her
oh she's here okay yeah and then is jubo
here
i see going mean yeah shubo's here okay
perfect
then everyone's here we're ready okay
great um
okay so um i will give a brief
introduction and not take too much of
his time
um so um nate is known to
uh many of us in the department he's a
phd candidate
in the bioinformatics and computational
biomedicine major
he originally studied biological physics
at the university of washington
and then worked as a mechanical engineer
developing a lung cancer diagnostic
device
using 3d single cell imaging his
primary research goals are to develop
robust drug response models to aid
decision making in precision oncology
and his current work has broad
translational application and drug
development combination therapy
prediction
clinical patient response prediction and
patient therapy
toxicity prediction um
several of us many of us maybe actually
heard a wonderful
talk a couple weeks ago at the amia
symposium by josh denney on precision
medicine and so
we're attuned to this topic so again
he's going to present the current status
of his research at the symposium today
and will get feedback from us as he uh
develops his
proposal so i will turn it over to nate
thanks bill that was a great intro
sounds like some of my background
is already taken care of um
all right so has everyone seen my
slideshow here
yes yeah we see it fine excellent okay
so sorry
seem to have a screen in my screen
there we go okay so uh like bill said my
name is nate evans and today i'm gonna
be giving my symposium presentation
so the title that i've given this is
improving uncertainty quantification
in drug response to guide precision
oncology
and so a little bit of motivation for my
research
since coming to ohsu two years ago i've
worked in
a number of different labs with shannon
mcqueeny in the biodev lab and
dr coley's martin as well as more
recently
with dr gordon mills and all of these
labs have a lot of focus on precision
oncology tasks which have really guided
my
my interests and um and the work that
i'm going to present here today
but also you know my interest really is
in like bill said developing these drug
response models
and how we can use those for combination
therapy prediction
and drug research prioritization
so quick background on the talk today
i'll start with some
a brief overview of precision oncology
and some background
and then i i'm going to spend the first
part of the talk trying to
show the connections between decision
utility a concept called model
calibration
and then finally uncertainty
quantification
and then from there we'll move on to
applications of uncertainty
quantification
and drug response um and then we'll
finish up with
some of the the areas that i'm most
interested in pursuing
i'm kind of a teaser for my proposal
so precision oncology if um i think it's
it's becoming more and more popular
these days but uh
it's a bit of a shift away from a one
drug fits all
um style of medicine and it operates
under the assumption that there's
heterogeneity in patient
and tumor genomics and this is going to
lead to variation
in in therapeutic response and so the
goals of precision oncology then
is to use ohmic profiling or
some kind of feature patient or tumor
feature to try to stratify these
patients for
in a way that can improve treatment so
we want to choose the optimal therapy
based on those tumor characteristics or
the patient characteristics
and there's there's huge potential here
definitely to
improve patient outcome that's the
primary goal
but also there's uh significant work
being done to reduce toxicities and side
effects
and then finally in the in the long run
we also think this might be able to
reduce financial burden but that's
that's kind of a you know long-term goal
and so to get to this to get to the kind
of
the potential of precision oncology
requires a lot of research
and there's still some pretty
significant bottlenecks so
in this figure at right it really
identifies a lot of these issues where
we start out with a ton of drugs and
through the development process
there's a significant attrition rate and
so to go from
um from a brand new drug to you know
drug discovery to
uh fda approved drug could take
10 to 20 years and by some estimates
around two to three billion dollars and
so this is
um a huge obstacle uh
and we want to try to improve this
there's a lot of reasons why um
this is such an issue and we're actually
going to talk a lot more
more about those the sources of
uncertainty and
why we see such high drug attrition
rates throughout this talk
so another task in precision oncology um
that's gained a lot of effort in the
last few years or the last 10 years is
this idea of drug combination therapy um
and there's a number of reasons why this
is valuable
uh number one is that when you use
monotherapies we see
oftentimes we see good initial response
followed by
um either tumor resistance or metastases
and
and this is we think this is due to
tumor heterogeneity
and so if we have multiple cancer clones
in a tumor
then a single monotherapy often acts as
a selective pressure and you
get evolved resistance over time and so
one approach to this is that by using
combination therapies we may be able to
you know reduce or improve the
durability of response
and prevent those uh that tumor
resistance or metastases
another concept here is that there's
often multiple type of genes in the
cancer and so by targeting
all of those or multiple of those driver
genes we may be able to improve
efficacy of that of that therapy
there's also a concept of drug synergy
where uh
the the response to
a combination therapy is much better
than would be predicted by either of the
single monotherapies together and and
this has a lot of value in reducing
toxicity um it can also improve the
therapeutic window
and so when we try to find these drug
combinations
um it's usually done through high
throughput screening with
those response assays but what i want to
draw attention to on the right here is
that
this um this is a fairly
complicated or very large uh search
space
and so on the x-axis we have the number
of drugs we're choosing from
and on the y-axis in in log 10 we have
the number of possible combinations and
this is a fairly
simple combinatorics problem but you can
see that we have very
high exponential growth and depending on
how many drug combinations you're
looking at
this becomes incredibly problematic and
just to provide a little context
uh the broad repurposing hub which is a
major repository for
information related to drug repurposing
or combinations
has over six 000 drugs included
so that that search space is is
incredibly large
and when you add the genomic access or
the ohmic access here it becomes even
more complex
and that kind of brings us to the role
of drug response prediction
um there's a number of reasons why we
use drug response models in precision
oncology
um as as i kind of alluded to we want to
use them to prioritize
uh different therapies for high
throughput screening or for further
research
there's also some really fantastic work
being done in
you know chemotherapeutic choices for
patients so
in breast cancer there's two screens
oncotype dx and mammoprint
that are both used to
to help physicians choose which therapy
is going to be most valuable
and then in research settings we
definitely want to use our
drug response models to understand the
underlying biology
and so there's a lot of value there and
then lastly
in today's in today's research settings
we have a huge amount of data
um you know all kinds of different
sequencing technologies coming out
and we can produce um you know an
incredible number of features
for a given tumor but the issue is that
you know us humans aren't great
at integrating that all together and
using it in any actionable way and so
that's
another fantastic role that uh these
these statistical models can try to fill
uh and then so just a little more um
context about the top i'm going to be
primarily talking about
cell line models um and so when we build
a statistical model for
cell lines or any model system usually
we're usually using dose response curves
to measure that functional response and
that's characterized by
two metrics either the area under the
dose response curve
that you see or the inhibitory or the 50
inhibitory constant ic50 and so i'll
probably be referring to those
throughout the talk
uh and then inputs are commonly bulk
sequencing of
um of monoclonal cultures and
we'll talk a little more about how we
encode drugs there's a number of ways to
do that
so um
you know as everyone would probably
expect there's a ton of
research being done here there's a lot
of different
incredible models that have already been
developed this
drug cell was published october of this
year
and it's actually a really incredible
paper if anyone has interest in
in this field but i think it represents
you know
state-of-the-art drug response
predictions
and what i'm trying what i want to show
here is the model on right
the x-axis is all the different drug
response models or predictive value of
the drugs
and then on the y-axis we have the
performance and they use spearmint
correlation there and so in red on left
these are pretty high performing model
or
high performing drugs that are quite
predictable
but uh the the blue or purple
on right these are not as well
performing and we
recognize that there's a huge number of
these so this really represents a lot of
room for improvement and
work still to be done
and there's a number of reasons why
uh we still have such a variable
response um
this is probably
[Music]
what i think about most often that the
data types that we use in these models
are
incredibly noisy and so what we're do
the graph on right
is comparing three of the
the primary public pharmacological data
sets uh ccle gdsc
and ctrp and so
and what it's looking at is for a given
cell line and drug combination
between these three data sets how close
do those values
correlate and so the correlation is on
the y-axis there
and you can see that except for these
adjusted metrics
almost none of the metrics have a
correlation above 0.6
and for context that last model
last model i showed you they used ctrp
and gdsc
and so if we're building drug response
modeling
models using these data types we're
going to be fundamentally limited
by this noise or this poor concordance
and there's a number of reasons why that
is
which we'll get into even more later on
so there's kind of two ways to approach
this um the first
is uh the first is that we want to
understand where we have uncertainty in
drug response data types and improve
upon that
and and that's you know that that's
definitely something that we all want to
work on but
the second way is to say uh even if we
have
moderate performing drug response models
can we use these
can we use these predictions in an
actionable way and that brought me to
uncertainty quantification
and these are some papers that kind of
echo my my thoughts that we really need
to start incorporating this
so to understand what uncertainty
quantification is it's it's
first i first need to introduce this
idea of
calibration and so when we think of
model performance
i think a lot of us at least um or at
least myself
initially thought of discrimination so
that's the ability to
predict a correct value and the metrics
for this are
accuracy and sensitivity specificity or
auroc
but there's kind of another branch to
model performance which is the ability
to
assess our uncertainty in the predicted
value
and this is what we call calibration
there's a number of metrics we can use
especially in classification and
classification problems
but we'll look at calibration plots
today
so a calibration plot um
it attempts to evaluate how well a model
characterizes its uncertainty
and so on the x-axis we have the
predicted probability
of some of some observation and then on
the y-axis we have
the true probability and this is
to implement this it's usually done
using bins so for instance for a model
between or for
for any model you would take all
predictions between probability 0.5 and
0.6
and you would ask how many of those had
uh had a positive and so for this model
characterized by the blue line it has
almost
0.85 so that's really quite high
um and what we would like to see a
perfect model
or a well-calibrated model would lie
right along the diagonal
as that would encode the uncertainty
properly
one other aspect to consider when when
thinking about these calibration plots
is
the distribution of probabilities that
are predicted
and so in this example we can see that
you know probabilities between 0.9 and 1
are almost never predicted
and so the majority kind of lie in these
two these two humps around point three
and point seven
and that really um is another
factor in in actionability of uh
predictions here so as a quick
example of why these calibration plots
are useful it allows us to
kind of discretize model performance
especially in terms of probability and
so for that red line
right we can say that around 10 of the
observations
have predicted probabilities between 0.5
and 0.6
and of these 85 percent of the
observations are correct
um and so for this model it actually
significantly it's it's significantly
under confident it underrepresents the
predicted probabilities between
0.5 and 0.6
and another another kind of interesting
aspect of why
these curves are useful is in the same
way that
we we can characterize humans as
confident or underconfident and
and that affects our ability to trust
them we can we can kind of do the same
thing with
uh these predictive models so this upper
one
represents kind of uh an over confidence
and the the lower curve represents under
confidence
and just to provide a human example of
this
my fashion sense is very overconfident
so you know something to be aware of
there's a number of reasons why we
should care about calibration
it's really important when we want to
use our predictions for decision making
and i'll show why
but even more so if there are costs
associated with with predictions
and then probably most applicable to
my research it can be very
useful if our models have poor
discrimination performance
you know and that could be due to noisy
data types or
perhaps low data volume
i also really like this example i think
it shows um
you know it's useful for showing why
calibration um
is something we should pursue so in a
lot of clinical and research settings
there are already decision making
processes in place
and so this kind of lets us incorporate
model predictions on a
a case-to-case basis and
the advantage of this is that we can
mitigate risk by
only letting a modeling um incorporate
its
its predictions when it's very confident
um and in a well
calibrated model that means that we can
use the tails this distribution where
it's you know quite confident down here
and quite confident up here
and only use those predictions and kind
of disregard
um the region where where we're
uncertain about uh
prediction value um
but but it's critical here that our
model calibration
that we have good model calibration
okay so next i want to show the
relationship between model calibration
and decision utility
and so to do that i'm going to introduce
these decision curves
they were originally developed to
evaluate
clinical decision utility of a
predictive model
and but i'm going to try to explain why
they're
they're useful in in general
so on the x-axis we have you can think
about this as
preference or consequence and it's in
terms of
threshold probability so what threshold
do we use to
to choose an intervention or a positive
essentially
and then on the y-axis we have net
benefit
to the process that we're interested in
and we compare against baselines so
this uh slanted black line is
intervention for all
and then this bottom line is
intervention for none
and so the difference between our model
curve
in light gray and those those bass lines
are
uh are is essentially improvement
on the the decision process and if you
do have another model or a diagnostic
test you may be
comparing against those baselines
and so there's this great paper and what
they did is they compared
three models with identical
discrimination performance
but then they varied the calibration of
the model and what they showed is that
this first line um the light gray can
people see my pointer
i hope so um the light gray
here yes okay thank you
is a perfect uh calibration
but as the calibration gets worse um
that decision utility
also gets significantly worse and even
more so
we can notice that it's actually worse
than no intervention at all so there's
negative contribution to this
this decision process and that's
definitely something we want to be
you know pretty aware of if we're if
we're developing a model that has
any kind of input into a decision
process this calibration becomes
quite quite valuable
okay so that was a a lot of background
but putting it together i hope that i've
shown
that in this drug response field we have
quite variable predictions and
there's a lot of room for improvement
and one of the the concepts here is that
model calibration is
has been in a lot of cases overlooked i
think in this field
and we can improve the actionability of
some of these drug response
predictions if we can also improve those
model calibration
so the next question is how can we
improve model calibration
and that brings us filing to uncertainty
quantification
so in a machine learning context we
traditionally use scalar metrics as um
scalar variables and as inputs and
outputs
and then moreover our parameters of the
model if we have a parametric model are
usually
scalars as well and what what this does
is
it collapses any uncertainty information
that we might have in uh in in
inputs or outputs or the model
parameters and so our goal here
is to start thinking about how can we
include that uncertainty so
we want to use distributions as our
input variables or as our output
variables and then there's also methods
that we can use
um distributions to characterize our uh
parameter models and what that does is
it allows us to propagate uncertainty
from
any of these sources into predictions
into
you know novel predictions
and so there's a number of ways to do
this we can sample from
input variables and propagate that
through
to prediction uncertainty there are also
ways to
try to um uh you know propagate our
inverse
or sorry propagate our uh output
variation back through model during
training
and then finally there are some some
methods that um
kind of implicitly characterize
uncertainty
so real briefly i'm not going to go into
depth on these methods
but there are a number that that do
implicitly characterize uncertainty
quantification
you can do this to some extent in in
frequentist methods and
and for instance you know most
classification tasks have some
element of uncertainty but to improve on
this
the bayesian field has really produced a
lot of fantastic methods and i'd say
the majority of the work has stemmed
from there
gaussian processes are probably one of
the go-to methods
um bayesian regression can do similar
things
however it's usually you know parametric
and then
you can also do uh bayesian neural
networks
and then more recently in the last 10
years or so deep learning has put a lot
of effort
into how to use uh probabilistic
models so variational autocoder auto
encoders can do a good job of that
there's been some work in using so
dropout
is a mechanism usually used for
um for regularization
however if you use dropout during
prediction
um then you can produce a essentially an
ensemble of predictions and
and quantify uncertainty this has been
shown to approximate a number of
bayesian
inference methods and then finally if
you set up your predictor your
prediction task
as uh as an interval task rather than a
single value you can also quantify
answers to be that way
in general there are you can break down
uncertainty into two
broad categories and the first being
alliatoric uncertainty
which we can think of as our irreducible
error
and on that on the left there we have
high alliatoric uncertainty
and on the right we're going to have low
low uncertainty
and then the other form is epistemic
uncertainty and that's where we just
don't have enough data to
to characterize the model at all and
both of these can contribute
um to uncertainty and predictions it can
actually can be quite difficult to
separate the uncertainty in some cases
so before we go into types of uncertain
or
sources of uncertainty in drug response
i just wanted to
give a little context in if we do
uncertainty quantification
well um what methods or algorithms
essentially what are the applications
for this
so one of the ones that i'm most
interested in um is
task or cost optimization and there's a
number of algorithms
that use um use the
the upper confidence bounds to try to
optimize some given
function this is uh you know bayesian
optimization is one of those
there's also a bandit algorithm
as we've talked about a little bit
already there's a lot of application and
decision utility
through improving calibration
there's been some some examples where
they were able to improve analysis by
quantifying that uncertainty
this is a really interesting concept
where if we include uncertainty
in um in our interpretation mechanisms
then
um we add this this new axis of
you know we believe that it that this
prediction was made for this reason
but we have some level of confidence on
it
it's also shown that uncertainty
quantification can affect so if you
provide
a confidence metric to a human user
that affects how likely they are to use
the
the prediction for some some
task and then finally there's
applications in risk mitigation
uh and then in precision oncologies
these have pretty broad application
to combination therapy prediction to
drug repurposing
and and then certainly in in developing
clinically actionable models
or for patient stratification
okay so for the next
10 or 15 minutes i'm gonna go over
where we find uncertainty what's what
the sources are of uncertainty and drug
response
so in general we can have
we can have uncertainty in any of our
inputs
or in our outputs and then we also need
to recognize that
most of my work is in model systems
and so we develop these predictive
models using cell lines or in some cases
we might use
mouse models but they're really only
valuable if they predict
patient tumor response in some way and
so that external validity becomes very
important and we know that there's
there's a lot of reasons that our model
systems don't always
agree with with patient response
and then one other thing as i go through
this
recognize that i'm trying to explain
where the why there's
you know variation or uncertainty in in
this field
and what's been done to address it so
far
but if we can't address it or
needs more work there then we want to
think about how can we quantify the
uncertainty
to improve the actionability of those
predictions kind of two two sides there
okay so drug encoding is um
is important for as that input variable
for for
drug perturbation there's a number of
ways to do it
you know probably the most naive way
would just be used
factors however
there's also been success using
molecular structures
the one the the encoding that i'm most
interested
in is thinking about it as a protein
target
right and so to understand that
we we have to think about the
pharmacological models
of protein ligand binding and this on at
right here
is a simplified version of this where we
have
an inactive protein and when the drug
binds it stabilizes the
active conformation and produces some
downstream effect
and then what's really important to re
to know in this scenario is the
proportion of
unbound or free proteins and drug
to the bound complex and that's
characterized by our dissociate
dissociation constant
which we sometimes call them binding
affinity
and so if we know uh which proteins a
drug binds to and the binding affinity
for that
for that given drug protein then
we can characterize a drug's
perturbation on a model system
and i think that uh the pathway
um provides a lot of context in this so
this is the
uh the map k pathway and
we can think about you know a lot of a
lot of these systems have a receptor
tyrosine kinase
and then a signaling cascade that ends
in transcription factors that lead to
some measurable change
and so encoding our drugs as these
these protein targets we can think of
disrupting that
pathway or that signaling cascade to try
to change
to change cell behavior
another issue in this drug encoding when
we're thinking about it as protein
targets
is we really need to know
all the targets that a protein might
affect and this can be problematic
because
there are known and unknown targets
depending on how well studied a drug
is so imatinib for instance is a fairly
well studied drug it was
developed to treat chronic myeloid
leukemia
specifically to target able 1 originally
but
through more research we found that it
had a lot of
secondary targets so all these different
colors represent different targets
and this plot shows the level of
evidence for different binding
affinities of this target and so we can
see that we have kind of
inconsistent drug data and there's you
know significant uncertainty there
moreover if we look at other
pharmacological constants
we see additional
additional variants and so this can be
really difficult if we want to encode
drugs in this way it can be difficult to
know
all of the all of the protein targets
uh so another important factor here is
that
different drugs can create different
effects in a in a system
and so that model that i described
earlier that would be
a agonist where it binds to the protein
and creates some downstream effect
however kinase inhibitors which are a
really common
class of drug that we use in precision
oncology
would probably be considered an
antagonist or potentially an inverse
agonist
where it binds to a a protein
or a kinase and it stabilizes the
inactive conformation preventing
signaling
and so recognizing that different drugs
will behave different ways
and that we need to understand that
mechanism of action if we're going to
encode them in a
in a reliable way is actually quite
important
and that's that's information we don't
always have
okay so moving on to our second input
variable
which is our our ohmic encodings um
i like to start with this concept that
um
we really have to deal with with
surrogate variables and
that's kind of shown or can be shown
with the paradigm concept and so
paradigm was this pathway modeling
algorithm
developed in in 2010 and they did a
great job of
uh incorporating the the central dogma
of biology
in a factor graph and so they were able
to encode
you know dna um genomics
in this left node and then rna
expression
if we had protein expression we might be
able to include that
with the goal of trying to model protein
activity and what's really important to
recognize is that
drug response really lives in this right
node in protein activity
and so we're trying to um we're trying
to understand that
but we have some separation with the
variables that we're actually measuring
um and for anyone who doesn't work
with this stuff rna expression and dna
mutation is probably
it's just far easier to measure those
than it is to measure protein or protein
activity
and so we we definitely have that
separation there and that can
result in quite a bit of uncertainty
uh as it's a quick side note there was
this fantastic paper
developed in 2016 um
where the this was from the califano lab
and they took a bit of a divergent
approach where they said rather than
looking upstream
of protein activity let's look
downstream
and if we know genes that are regulated
by a given
protein we can try to infer that
protein's activity levels
and it's seen this algorithm has seen
really really incredible results so
i'm excited to see where that goes
another source of uncertainty in these
in the genomic encoding
is um either
heterogeneity in our cells or or the
lack of
variation that we're able to measure and
so in my work we
majority work with monoculture
cell lines and measure
the genomics using bulk sequencing and
what's important to recognize is that
bulk sequencing is an average of all our
cells
and so if we have any
variation due to it could just be
biological variants like
transcriptional bursting or if there's
any transient cell states
um then we're going to collapse that
into a into a single value and that that
can be problematic
um so this plot at the bottom kind of
shows how
if there is variance we collapse that
into a single point
uh and this this becomes far more
problematic if you think of a marginal
distribution where there might be
um you know complex or
bimodal distributions
oh one other aspect to consider is there
has been some work
in deconvolving bulk sequencing into
individual signals i i believe this is
more appropriate
if you know which cell types it might be
included and so
it's kind of dubious whether it be
valuable to monocultures but it's
definitely some valid
work in the field
okay so moving on to our output
variables
drug response like i said before drug
responses
in cell lines are usually characterized
by dose response curves
and since around 2012 there's actually
been
a number of papers that showed a growth
rate bias
um which kind of confounded a lot of
these
and then more recently the soldier lab
put out
this paper where they showed really
definitively that
important important metrics summary
metrics like ic50 that we talked about
before
and emacs which is another important
important parameter that characterized
these dose response curves
are highly correlated with a cell
division rate
and so a faster a cell grows um
the lower the ic50 or the higher the
ic50 rate is
and so this is a problem because um
when we use these metrics in drug
response we want them to
encode drug response not not cell
division rate that's a separate
separate piece of information
and so the point is that we have quite a
bit of uncertainty in these
classical drug response metrics there
has been some really great work
this was also done by the soldier lab
where they developed a new metric they
called it
gr which stands for growth rate
normalization
and in simulations they were able to
show that
this gr metric is robust to
cell proliferation rate whereas ic50
um or ec 50 are not
so that's a significant improvement in
the field there's also a number of
other reasons why we see a lot of
variation in drug response
experimental conditions can be have a
massive factor
and then there's also processing
components
another concept here is that we
we currently don't do a great job in
coding
you know dealing with the time axis of
drug response
so when we measure a cell line's
response to a drug
we usually do it at a single a single
time point it might be 48 hours or might
be 90 hours
but uh there's also been
work so this plot at right is showing
one cell line's response to
the drug uh um omit policy
and what you can see is that the
gr50 that metric that characterizes the
drug response
changes depending on when you measure it
and it changes pretty significantly and
so if you measure this at a discrete
time point say 48
hours you're going to get a very
different value than if you measure it
at
90 hours
it should be noted that
that i suspect this was a bit of a
cherry-picked example
that not all drugs and cell lines will
behave this way a lot are far more
um stable but the fact that this
is a possibility um really you know
contributes to uncertainty in our drug
response
and finally
finally we have uncertainty in that
external validity so like i
talked about before we have we are
working in model systems to build these
drug response
um these drug response models
and we do that because we really can't
find we can't produce enough data
in humans or we can't measure what we
want to measure in humans um
and so we we really have to work in
model systems but the goal is that we
want
these model systems to be representative
of the human and
there's a lot of issues with this for
instance we know we're going to lack
immune response in both
cell lines and mouse models the
pharmacodynamics and the
pharmacokinetics will be quite different
and then in a lot of cases so in mouse
models you might be able to recreate a
micro environment to some extent but in
cell lines you won't be able to
to do that and then there's also this um
this growing work in tumor heterogeneity
that we know contribute pretty
significantly to drug response
and that's something that can be very
difficult
to do in in these these simple model
systems at least
okay so before i wrap up
i wanted to give a bit of a teaser for
my proposal uh
i hope i've kind of shown the
relationship between calibration
um and uncertainty quantification and
how that can improve decision utility
and then a number of sources of
uncertainty in drug response but
it's kind of three primary error areas
that
i would like to kind of address moving
forward
one i think there's a lot of room for
improvement in quantifying uncertainty
in our drug response metrics so those
the issues we see with ic50 or or auc
and i think we can improve this by
trying to
use probabilistic models to fit dose
response curves and then propagate the
uncertainty onto those summary metrics
and by doing that we can improve model
calibration
the second uh the second second avenue
here is
i think there's some pretty clever
things we can do in encoding drugs
as edge modifiers in a protein protein
interaction network
by doing this we gives us a really
flexible and
mechanistic way of of encoding these
drugs
and then finally this culminates in
a bit of a complex idea but bayesian
optimization is often used to
optimize some cost intensive task for
instance they do it in
for hyperparameter optimization
sometimes in
machine learning but it's also been
shown to work well for
um for drug development
um or chemical design and the idea is
that if you can build a
continuous distributed representation of
that that represents your system so this
would be a one-dimensional
um version of that and then you have
some
metric that characterizes
how you know uh characterizes the
response to the system whether it's a
a good drug or a bad drug then you can
try to use these upper confidence
bounds to suggest regions that are going
to be more
uh effective than other regions and so i
want to use that to
um to prioritize drug combinations
and i'll be talking a lot more about
that next quarter i hope
so in summary uh
in summary we can improve model
calibration by
improving decision utility we can
that if we do this if we improve model
calibration we can improve
uh sorry that by using uncertainty
quantification we can improve model
calibration
uh that we're kind of limited by
these noisy data types in precision
oncology and
and that the huge search space required
for combination
therapeutics is uh really
predicates that we need some
hybridization methods
i hope i've gone over kind of a broad
broad strokes on sources of uncertainty
we have in this field
and then finally uq can really enable
powerful algorithms
um and that are broadly applicable to
precision oncology
so with that i will acknowledge
the deep mice department and staff and
all the students that helped me get here
uh the closed martin lab for their help
and then and in the mills lab as well
more recently and then finally my
um my advisor team uh
dr aurora blitzer and dr shannon
mcqueeny and i'll take any questions
great um thanks thanks nate for an
interesting talk i guess um
one question i have is someone who um
kind of lives
more in the clinical world and and less
in the
in in the in the weeds of the models
that you presented
um has have these approaches um achieved
success in repurposing drugs are there
examples that can be pointed to um
that some aspect of this um
has you know led to some therapeutic
advancement
uh yeah so are you talking about
this last aspect or just uncertainty
quantification in general
well i'm really talking about the big
picture so
um you know you know there's as
every clinical person knows there's
there are many
um you know uh diseases that can
that that could use better uh
therapeutics and i'm just wondering if
um
this repurposing uh approach which
is is very logical has has actually
resulted
in um you know benefit um some
drug being repurposed for for cancer or
covenanting or or any other condition
i don't have any uh explicit
examples of of a drug that's been
effectively prioritized but
um i can't say so drug cell one of those
that model that i
introduced really early that's actually
seen a lot of
that it's really valuable for re for
prioritizing
combination therapies and i think just
in
in general it's due to that intractable
search space we
we're always trying to use these
predictive models to improve
uh you know to guide our research
efforts
good okay there's a there's a question
in the chat and
and others can feel free to either
unmute or type into the chap there's a
question from
um ted on um are you going to have a
clinician on your committee
somewhat related to the question i just
asked
yeah that's a great question um i would
like to
i i haven't settled on a committee yet
but um but i think that would be a
really valuable contribution yeah
he is working this is shannon he is
working though in a i mean
gordon mills is a is a condition right
so he's been working
with gordon and um and and actually been
doing work in his lab as well so he is
getting some exposure to that
yeah good
any other any other questions
ned is going to be it's a really great
talk so
i have several questions as a member of
your committee
okay so do you have a actual like uh
initial but uncertainty since the whole
theme about the symposium about
uncertainty like what we can really
assign some kind of factors or some kind
of things
into uncertainty otherwise it seems to
be especially
the last 10 slides seems like
uncertainty
is everywhere so but as in
statistics as you see basically is tried
to really
handle all this uncertainty right
yeah so then we have statistically
already available like
all your models actually we can
basically just
plug in a probabilistic terms
of like a prediction model even
owning the french equation models we can
plug
in probabilistic balance terms
seeing automatic convert all these
models into
some kind of like ucr a certain
quantification
so so my question
if making shot is do you have actual
definition about this a certain
yeah um that's a that's a great point
that you know statistical methods
uh they all try to do this anyways
um so when when i say uncertainty
quantification the goal is really to
um to be using
uh distribution forms of
of our inputs and outputs and those
model parameters and
in a lot of cases we collapsed that
even in statistics and in that um
in my opinion um it
limits how much information which is
relevant to model calibration and limits
that
um and so i would i would focus on
uncertainty um as
as what can be encoded in a distribution
form rather than a scalar metric
you know that's it's not a fantastic
definition but
but yeah okay so
another question is so about this
model performance evaluation so
basically we have
classical like discrimination method
using sensitivity specificity a you see
other kind of thing
and then you see we have success first
time i
got about this collaboration so what
exactly differs like from one left hand
side can we actually
try to do also calibration in other
words can we use the same data set
to do both discrimination and the
collaboration for model
performance evaluation
yeah yeah so you could evaluate both
discrimination and calibration on the
same test set
the same at holdout test set um
but you know it does require the same uh
machine learning principles of of
creating a hold-out test at or doing
cross-validation
um okay so is there some kind of
difference requirement for the actual
data
side for doing these two different
collaborations
different evaluation
not that i know of uh it's definitely
some different metrics
different ways you think about um
about the performance
but as for for evaluation i i think you
can treat them fairly similarly
so for example if we have a classifier
as a machine learning model so for
discrimination based
basically we can have only true or false
but then can we do collaboration since
we cannot really see the actual
probability in the different
discrete things if you go to the next
slide
so you basically see yeah you need to
know all these kind of
scores right right right
so if your model predicted only binary
values you
i don't think you'd be able to yeah you
would not be able to
evaluate model calibration but
in most classes or in a lot of
classification tasks i think that we
we usually predict probabilities and
then use a threshold to to
you know binarize those further and so
if you're dealing with those predicted
probabilities you could still
you could still characterize this
calibration
i also i might have i might have missed
this point but uh
you can also do model calibration with
regression tasks
um you just have to be you have to use
the quantiles in a little bit different
of a way
but that almost all the all the work
still applies
okay
that's interesting i guess it's very
difficult really to get
the golden standard the golden data set
to really use it as a reference to do
collaboration
right since you need to have all these
different
scores but actually you get these
goals especially like yeah you classify
the environment right right
and you know one of the reasons that i
suspect um
calibration has been kind of overlooked
in the past is that
uh if you have really fantastic
discrimination
then this becomes somewhat irrelevant
you know if you're working in
95 accuracy range then
it becomes less important to be thinking
about calibration
however if you have you know moderate or
poor performing models
then calibration becomes absolutely
critical
to to using it in an actionable way okay
okay thank you i yeah i should have give
other people some minutes
hey nate this is ben um i have a
question to
really enjoy the talk um i just wanted
to ask
for a clarification on one of the things
you mentioned regarding when that model
outputs a scalar
um if the model were a neural network
and you were using dropout to do the
kind of approximate division um for the
calibration
would you could still have a scalar
output and wouldn't you just
resample it based off of this static
input while
applying dropout is that correct
uh yeah so that's um that that is one
way that they've tried to implement
these um these uncertainty
quantification methods i think
they sometimes call that monte carlo
dropout or
or drop out of a prediction and and yeah
i was able to
approximate a number of bayesian
inference methods using that
okay cool that's really interesting yeah
it's cut it's pretty clever huh
yeah cool well uh thanks
there's another um question in the chat
from rory
i can you see it nate yeah
um so rory asked do you have some
thoughts on how you might approach
handling concordance
or disagreement of data types
um for instance if i'm using rna or
protein data
yeah that's a that's a great point um
i suppose in that example it depends
so it really depends on what we want to
infer so
in that central dogma um you know
model protein is going to be far closer
to protein activity than our rna so i
would probably weight it
you know i would wait protein more
heavily
[Music]
but but that's definitely um yeah
definitely an interesting concept
i'll have to think about that one a
little more
any other questions
if not um we'll um we'll look forward to
your coming back and defending your
dissertation proposal and and see which
direction you want to head and and go
from there
thank you i appreciate it everyone
watching and
the help bill great um thanks everyone
and uh
we'll see you at the next conference
which i believe is next
bye